сьогодні в Україні люди які
розуміються на політиці розділилися на
два табори перший найчисленніший
це ті люди, які вважають що при владі
ідіоти що влада тупа підтвердження
цьому просто маса ми читаємо новини в
будь-якими 3 мені вранці вдень увечері
хапаємось за голови причому які ж не
тупі що ж не робить це чутно з
кожного вікна по всій країні другий
табір друга група людей менш
численні вони вважають, що при владі
корумповані люди що влада
корумпована для коробки сьогодні
поговоримо трохи більш детально брия
найбільший літак України
великий літак світу саме наше
серйозне досягнення час що мрії
здійснюються чижі мрії здійснюються компаніям
чи я
medical компанія зареєстрована 23
січня 2020 року
бардак чонко диана миколаївна напевно
її мрії справдилися вам велике привітання
діана миколаївна
за 20 тисяч гривень статутного капіталу 20
тисяч гривень божевільні гроші вона
зареєструє у компанію та брала участь
у тендері тендер який проводила
міністерство внутрішніх справ України
центральний госпіталь міністерства
внутрішніх справ України проводив тендер
на закупівлю апаратів штучної
вентиляції легень 51 мільйон сто
п'ятдесят тисяч гривень вартість 50
апаратів тобто вартість одного
А зараз ми стежимо просто за
руками та за цифрами вартість одного
апарату 1 мільйон сто тисяч гривень
я ніколи в житті не продавав апарати та
нудної вентиляції легень продавав все
багато всього різного цікавого але
штучної вентиляції легень не
займався тим вони травня скільки ж повинен
коштувати апарат штучної вентиляції
легень
якби ви коли-небудь працювали в
постачанні ви знали як проходить
процедура підписання рахунків фінансового
директора чи директора директор не
може підписати просто так рахунок на
оплату чогось він від вас вимагає
завжди провести маркетингові
дослідження з'ясувати скільки ж той
самий товар коштує у інших постачальників
скільки він коштував вчора скільки він винен
коштувати взагалі дорого це або дешево в
давайте проведемо з вами там
маркетингові дослідження це дуже
навіть зробити нескладно повірте мені ми з
вами відкриваємо сайт виробника
апарат майстерної вентиляції легень
зробив у китаї китайський виробник
скільки ж коштує цей апарат у Китаї
сьогодні китає цей апарат коштує 8800
доларів ми не будемо зараз рахувати як
вважають добрий господар хороший директор
про те, що ми купуємо їх цілих 50 і це
опт і потрібно вимагати ще знижку від
номінальної вартості
окей ми порахуємо 8800 доларів у
сьогоднішньому курсі він був 27 і 14 це
складає 239 тисяч гривень одна штука
239 тисяч
гривень ok це в китаї на сайті можливо
це потрібно ще привести в Україну за там
можете розмитнити оформити документи
туди взято окуляри там якесь відкрити вікно
і так далі так далі ціна природно
виростає ми це розуміємо з вами ми діти
дорослі чудово знаємо як влаштована в
нас в Україні
економік ми можемо відкрити попередні
тендери скільки ж за попереднім
адже тендерам напевно апарати
мистецтво вентиляції легень постійно
покупець купувалися лікарнями та
шпиталі раніше скільки ж коштує апарат
та смачної вентиляції легень в Україні
виявити зовсім навіть не складно
увагу дивимося той самий апарат з
тим самим кодом апарат штучної
вентиляції легень
тендер на 350 тисяч гривень
19-го серпня 2019-го руку 350 тисяч
гривень про чикаго на vortice переможець
запропонував вартість 349 тисяч 300 гривень
349 тисяч 300 гривень ще раз цифра номер
3 340 9300
гриль
давайте порахуємо це не складну
математику це буде вашим домашнім
завданням 1 мільйон сто тисяч гривень
мінус двісті тридцять дев'ять тисяч
гривень помножимо це все на 50 штук і це
буде ваше домашнє завдання ви
порахуєте цю цифру і зробіть висновки
я вам поки що розповім бонус вишенька на
тортик як же українці справи з
апаратами штучної вентиляції
легень скільки їх потрібно і чиї мрії
збуваються
а че ні на сайті міністерство охорони
здоров'я україни ми з вами знайдемо список
опорних лікарень куди надходять люди з
підозрами на коронавірус сьогодні і з
підтвердженими діагнозами коронавірус в
цьому списку лікарень якщо ми з вами
заб'ємо у пошук слова госпіталь ми знайдемо
тільки один-єдиний госпіталь
це
лівійський обласний госпіталь у тирані
провини то
риб мальованих і там же на сайті
міністерства охорони здоров'я ми можемо з
вами знайти скільки ж
на сьогоднішній день на балансі лікарень
госпіталі знаходиться
апаратів штучної вентиляції
легенів у цьому госпіталі в
львівському апараті штучної
вентиляції легень всього 5 всього 5 київ
на сьогоднішній день це місто з
найбільшою кількістю заразився
коронавірусом і ймовірно їх
кількість буде зростати на жаль
всіх заражених у Києві
везуть до лікарні до олександрівського
який є опорним пунктом по
прийому та боротьби з коронавірусом в
києві
скільки ж апаратів штучної
вентиляції легень знаходиться в
олександрівської лікарні
дані відкриті та 49 апаратів 49
центральний госпіталь МВС закуповує
я не проти того, щоб центральний
госпіталь та закуповував апарату
штучної вентиляції легких їх
мабуть більше мені виникає тільки
два питання перше питання чи вистачить у
вас фахівців лікарів, які змогли
б обслуговувати
ці апарати та питання номер два
вартість цих апаратів зробивши
нескладні обчислення ви вже у своїй
голові можливо ви на калькуляторі
підрахували та робіть якийсь
певний висновок я б не поспішав з
висновками
я б зробив висновок наступні два табори
людей які розуміються на політиці це
табір людей які стверджують що
влади ідіоти другий табір
стверджують, що при владі корупції вони
корумповані і чи
ідіоти сьогодні влада задом я такий
питання і можна зробити досить
певні висновки
від вас лайк та підписка плюс коментар
з вашими думками з цього приводу від мене
нові відео із кумедною математикою
підтримуйте українські блогерів поки
[музика]